hey what is up guys and que PhD here and
this is the Oppo find 7 a so what Oppo
actually did recently was they released
two phones at the same time the Oppo
find 7 and the Oppo find 7 a the 7 being
the higher end basically device that we
all expected and the 7 a being a sort of
a step down $100 cheaper a sort of a
little brother the 7 isn't out yet but
this 7 a is probably the best look we're
going to get obviously at what to expect
with the find 7 so without any more
confusion between the two names let's go
ahead and take a closer look at the fine
7a the little brother and see what makes
it so special so the design of this 7a
is going to be exactly the same as the
fine 7 and I really like the way this
phone looks and feels in the hand I
actually didn't at first but it really
grew on me and I'm a fan of it now now
don't get me wrong it's a big phone you
got to realize it has a 5.5 inch 1080p
display and the fine 7 will have a 5.5
inch 2560 by 1440 display so you can see
next to the galaxy s5 here which has a
5.1 inch display that it looks rather
large it's a lot bigger in the hand and
there's a lot of phone going on here no
doubt even next to the notoriously big
Galaxy Note 3 you're still looking at a
slightly taller phone on the Oppo side
so you're definitely looking at a big
phone but to tell you the truth I really
didn't notice like even if you didn't
hold the other phones you wouldn't
really think that this is a massive
phone it done a great job keeping the
bezels slim and a really trim handsome
profile so the phone doesn't actually
feel like a 5.5 inch phone really the
main way you know that it's solid and
well-built is its weight it's 170 grams
versus the all-metal 1m 860 and it
reminds me of that fine 5 from earlier
actually when the build materials are so
dense like this the whole glass front
the metal frame all around the sides
just the way the phone feels it screams
quality again reminds me exactly the
define 5 so I really do like the phone's
design like I mentioned it is quite thin
for its size it's got a pretty big
battery but it's still pretty light and
despite the fact that it's a smooth back
material it's still pretty easy to hold
it's not slippery like the HTC One was
because you have those edges of the
phone's to hold its its square instead
of round and another awesome point about
design the button placement is perfect
you have the power button right where
your hand falls nicely on the phone if
you holding your right hand you can
press the power button you can press the
volume keys that's really nice but
actually what I think it's one of the
coolest parts of the design of this
phone is in the chin of it right behind
the chin it's what Apple calls the
skyline notification light so there's
this big blue glowing LED notification
light behind the chin bar of this phone
it looks really nice thing is it is only
blue so obviously it's a notification
light so it would be nice to have like
red and yellow and green and different
colors to represent different things but
it is pretty cool it looks beautiful
when you're charging when you get a new
notification it pulses for your
vibrantly and it looks really cool along
the width of the phone so that's nice
and if the fine 7 doesn't have it at
least I think the next version Oppo you
should have a multicolor LED because
that would be super duper useful for a
lot of people so this one is rocking
Android 4.3 with a pose color OS on top
and we've seen color OS on their other
phones like the Oppo n1 and the Oppo
find 5 so we expected it again here on
the fine 7 it's got a lot of
improvements it's got a lot of
interesting nifty pro's and con's some
cool features that really make it a
unique experience it's really like no
other smartphone skin experience and I
like a lot of it so one big problem
everyone seems to have with one skin or
another whether its TouchWiz or HTC
Sense or Sony skin or whatever is just
the way it looks
aesthetics sometimes things just don't
look the way you want them to and I got
to be honest out of the box I really
didn't like the way color OS looks but
what's nice is they have a built-in
themer a whole store of free themes to
change the look of your launcher in your
homescreen so I actually have this
jellybean theme going on here so you can
see all of my icons and the whole
launcher resembles the experience of
stock Android so pretty similar to Nexus
now this doesn't change the look of
inside the applications obviously the
notification bar inside all the stock
apps they still look like color OS but
it definitely changes the feel of the OS
just by refreshing the launcher it just
feels different I'm staying with the
lockscreen actually the only reason I
have this sick lockscreen here is
because I found it in the lockscreen
themer which does the exact same thing
so he can choose different lock screens
download them locally store them and
basically switch between them whenever
you
you can totally change the look of your
lockscreen and there are a lot of them
it's a pretty robust store so color me
impressed there and yeah color OS has a
bunch of other things going for it one
is there's no on-screen buttons on this
phone so you have these very faint menu
home and back buttons that color OS
works with so remember how on the HTC
One m8 you can double tap to turn the
screen on but you still need the power
button to turn it off so Oppo has done
this same thing where you can double tap
to wake but now you can double tap that
home button to sleep the display as well
so in theory you now really never have
to touch the power button at all so
that's nice you also have some really
nice widgets some of these go really
fullscreen and hide the notification bar
they're super immersive we first saw
these on the Oppo find 5 and the
selection keeps growing and these things
keep evolving every time I see them so
that's cool
and of course you have access to a ton
of awesome wallpapers and you can even
change the homescreen swiping effect
right from that long press menu so lots
of nice stuff going on here lots of
shortcuts and I guess one of the most
significant shortcuts is gestures so
when you swipe down from the right hand
side anywhere on this phone you'll get
that regular notification shade of
course your quick settings your
brightness toggle your notifications etc
but when you swipe down from the left
corner down comes your oh so colourful
gesture panel so it comes programmed
with a pair of gestures already but you
can basically add anything you want you
can draw any shape with your finger and
have it map to launch any application or
call any contact or whatever you want a
by default drawing a circle will launch
the camera from wherever you are and
speaking of the camera this phone has an
excellent camera I don't want to say it
surprised me but I really didn't expect
it to be this nice of a camera and
that's coming from someone like me who's
used the Sony Xperia z1 iPhone 5s galaxy
s5 etc so first of all the user
interface it's nice it's very clean
simple intuitive and that's pretty
important too a nice camera experience
your Settings button on the bottom left
gets you access to all your normal
features like changing the photo
resolution up to the max 13 megapixels
or maxing out the 4k video recording
capability and this camera will even
shoot RAW images and it has a number of
other modes but what's really
interesting is the one button called HD
picture which is going to be renamed in
a software update to be called Ultra HD
this is being touted as the button that
will give you 50 megapixel pictures
though it's some software stitching
tricks involved so of course I turned it
on and I tried it and it kind of works
kinda so here's the thing so this is
what an image looks like taken at the
normal 13 megapixels right the image
here is 41 60 by 30 120 it's even got
some HDR going on so it's very detailed
throughout and this is what the crop
looks like of that skyline so when I
really get in close to that freedom
tower that's what it looks like okay so
then I press the magic button and take
another picture again this time with
Ultra HD on so now the resolution is way
bigger it's 81 60 by 60 120 and for the
record yes that is 50 mega pixels and
the overall picture you can see looks a
little flatter but what happens when I
crop here well it's definitely got a lot
of detail it looks a bit sharper but
side-by-side it's obviously not looking
quite as sharp as an actual 50 megapixel
camera would but really you wouldn't
expect it to it's a phone here basically
what I'm saying here is it's a law of
diminishing returns this particular
feature leaving this mode on it'll do as
best as it can with software stitching
to get as much detail out of the image
as it can and it does take an extra
second or two of processing to composite
this stuff so you might as well leave it
on for taking pictures of still subjects
but it doesn't look much better than say
a panorama photo from the galaxy s5
which can easily blow up to like 20
megapixels by itself I've done it so
what I'm trying to say here is don't
think of this as the 50 megapixel photo
mode just think of this as the enhanced
detail mode for still subjects just like
HDR mode is an enhanced dynamic range
mode for still subjects and for moving
subjects this camera is plenty fast
anyway the shutter is damn near instant
I was very confident taking photos with
this camera and the detail and regular
shots is pretty solid to begin with and
I'm a fan of the pretty aggressive HDR
processing in that mode on this camera
so you know what I'm a fan I'm a fan of
the camera on the 7a and I'm assuming
that will carry over to the Big Brother
find seven
that's available so the Oppo find 7 a
actually has a slightly smaller battery
than the fine 7 it has a twenty eight
hundred million power removable battery
but here's what's badass about this you
might have heard about it it's got this
really really fast charging technology
it's really not all that new technology
it just has a beast of a charger so
there's a special white charging brick
that comes with this phone and it's a
little intimidating at first but
essentially you'll notice that if you
look at like your normal phone charger
it's usually one amp maybe one and a
half amps and if you look at a tablet
charger that usually comes in at two
maybe two and a half amps this one we're
looking at here is a four and a half amp
charger it's going to throw way more
current through the battery and that
will in turn charge it way faster so you
have to use this exact model that comes
in the phone box if you want to get that
super fast charging I kind of wish I
could use a different one or maybe a
longer cable because out the box it's
only maybe about a meter long cable I
kind of wish it was longer more than
just three three and a half feet but
really it's all about using this power
brick to charge your phone ridiculously
fast so obviously with this ridiculously
powerful charger I was able to charge
this phone super fast obviously only
with this included charging brick but I
was able to go from 0% to 13% in five
minutes and if you do the percentage by
minute calculation this thing is
charging really fast so you can charge
your phone really quickly it'll go all
the way to 100% in just a couple minutes
but thing is the battery life actually
wasn't all that great you know obviously
using the phone a lot I'm using it
heavily when I'm testing it I'm gaming a
lot I'm doing a lot of web browsing a
lot of Twitter and I found that while
that kind of usage was normal that that
was all fine the standby time was really
weak compared to some other phones I've
used I just came off testing the Oppo
the HTC One m8 that had a fantastic
standby time you could forget to charge
it overnight and would have almost the
same amount of battery when you wake up
not so with this phone this phone is
going to drop 10 to 15% overnight I
could attribute that to the color OS the
ROM they have on this phone it could
just be some software tweaks they need
to work out some stuff running in the
background but for now I think they need
to work on the standby time and
hopefully it'll be able to last
as long as other phones with a 2,800
milliamp hour battery so overall you
know what I'm impressed with the 7a a
big beautiful screen in a nice design
and a phone like this and a
well-constructed package I really like
that obviously color OS will have plenty
of software updates and they're
constantly working on that we've seen
Oppo push updates
they've already pushed an update during
the time I've been testing the phone so
this gives you a pretty good idea of how
beastly the fine 7 is going to be when
that comes out with a 2.5 k display with
the 2.5 gigahertz quad-core processor
with three gigs of ram 3000 milliamp
hour battery that's going to be an even
more awesome experience but for now this
phone is pretty solid and if you don't
want to spend the extra hundred bucks
this is a pretty sweet option to
consider I like to find five I really
like to find seven a can't wait to check
out find seven so that's been it guys
thank you for watching if you enjoyed
the video feel free to hit that up
thumbs up button below and also there's
a subscribe button below so you don't
miss other reviews like this or tech
videos on this channel again thank you
for watching and I'll talk to you all in
the next one bass
member